welcome well there's been a lot of uh
news lately about what's going on with
bear stearns and and carlyle capital and
and i go to these parties and i start
explaining to people because it's very
exciting and it's actually very
important to all of our collective
futures and the whole health of the
financial system and i feel like
people's eyes start to glaze over
so with that in mind i decided to to
take a little bit of hiatus from kind of
the core math and physics videos and
actually do some some accounting and
finance videos because i think what's
happening in the world right now is
extremely extremely important
and i'm not just going to go straight
into what's going into you know carlisle
and thornberg and all of these
characters
because i think the newspapers do that
but a lot of people don't understand
kind of the basic accounting you know
what is a write down what does it mean
when you don't have liquidity
in really tangible ways so i'm going to
use kind of the same khan academy
techniques to hopefully explain some of
this so i'm going to start with just a
very basic accounting a basic accounting
concept of the balance sheet and you
might have a sense of what it is so
let's say a scenario let's say i want to
buy a house so this is let me draw a
house
so let's say this is the house
i want to buy
and the owner of this house is asking
for a million dollars for this house and
i like the house and i think that's a
fair price other houses in the
neighborhood also went for a million
dollars whatever maybe they went for
more so i think it's actually a good
deal
but all i have in my pocket all in all i
have in my pocket is
is
all i have is
say i have 250 000
so i have 250 000
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create my balance sheet before i do
anything before i go to try to get the
house so what is my pre my before house
balance sheet well what are my assets so
let's say i'm gonna write down assets
assets well before we know what my
assets are let me tell you what an asset
is an asset is something that has
that's going to give you some future
economic benefit so for example cash is
an asset why is cash an asset because in
the future you can use that cash to to
get stuff from people or make them do
things or buy stuff you can you know in
a month from now you can use your cash
and you can you can make someone dance
for you or you can
buy a car or you can go on vacation so
there's all sorts of things you can do i
don't know if someone's dancing for you
as an actual economic benefit but you
get the idea so cash could be an asset a
house could be an asset because the
economic benefit you get in the future
is you get to live in it and not freeze
when it's freezing outside so that's
what an asset is so what is what are my
assets before i buy the house or get a
loan or all of the things that are about
to happen well i have cash
and i have 250 000 dollars worth of cash
now what are my liabilities
liabilities i'm going to write the
liabilities on the left hand side
i think that's the convention but i
forget but it doesn't matter
what are my liabilities
well a liability is something that it's
an obligation to someone else kind of an
economic obligation to someone else so
if you know if i take a loan from
someone i owe them interest or i have to
pay them back the actual value of the
loan one day um say i have an iou where
i promise to dance for someone in the
future that that could be a liability it
would be hard to value but that's
something that i have to do in the
future
but what are my liabilities here well
the example i gave
i'm just sal i have no debt i've paid
off my college loans everything and i
have 250 000 in cash
so what are my liabilities before i buy
the house well nothing i don't have any
liabilities i don't owe anybody anything
and that's actually that to me is the
definition of freedom
so i have zero liabilities
so what is my
equity my equity and you've probably
heard this word people borrowing their
equity and all of these things so i'm
going to give you a little equation
actually just to take a little bit of a
tangent that
assets
assets a for assets
is equal to liabilities
plus equity
right
so in this case our assets are two
hundred fifty thousand dollars
my liabilities are what i owe no i know
i owe nothing to anyone to nobody i
don't know if that was correct but
anyway i owe nothing to anyone
so my liabilities are zero
so my equity must be
two hundred fifty thousand dollars
right my equity is also two hundred
fifty thousand dollars
so in this case if i made a balance
sheet before i enter into any
transactions and let me make it look a
little bit like a like a balance sheet
my assets are two hundred fifty thousand
dollars i have no liabilities
and then my equity
equity
would be two hundred fifty thousand
dollars
and if i were to draw this graphically
actually you should probably draw it
like this i have no liability so let me
let me draw another
little mini balance sheet here let me
draw as a neat square
you probably can't see that square
let me switch colors too
so
i put my assets on the right hand side
and i'll say there i have 250k of cash
and the left-hand side i have no
liabilities and i will just say i have
equity
of 250. now equity might not make a lot
of sense to you right now because i'm
kind of just saying well my equity is
equal to my cash in general equity is
just what you own what after all of your
assets and liabilities are kind of
resolved or they're cleared up what do
you have left over that's equity so in
this situation after i pay off all of my
debts what do i have left over well i
have no debts so i have 250 000 in cash
left over this will start to make sense
when i go to the bank now to get a loan
to buy this house
so this house is a million dollar house
right
so how much of a loan do i need well i
have 250 000 cash so
i'll go to the bank for a loan for the
remainder for 750 000
so let's let me draw
draw the bank
this is the bank the big dollar sign
it's made out of granite to show you
that it can never fail it's going to be
there forever
even if they do silly things
like well i won't go into all of the
silly things that they do but they do
many silly things we'll go in later but
the bank is going to
give me another
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars in
cash
right
and in return i'm giving them
essentially an iou
an iou and i'm going to pay interest
right so they're going to hold this
little security that says sal owes me
750 000 and he has to give me you know
10 interest every year so 75 000 a year
or something like that and in return i
get 750 000 in cash so what does my
balance sheet look like now
well let me draw it
let me make sure
my balance sheet now looks let me draw
it like a square because i think the
visual representation is helpful
so and then i will
split it
so what are all my assets now
i had 250 000
and now i got another 750 000 right i
got another 750 000 from the bank
so now what are my assets well 250 plus
i now have cash
of 1 million dollars 1 million dollars
what are my liabilities
well my liability
that's something that i owe to someone
else well i owe the bank seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars
so liabilities i'll just say l l for
liabilities because i'm running out of
space and my wife was complaining that i
make these things very hard to read but
what can i do anyway so my liabilities i
owe the bank seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars so that's a liability
and then the equity is
essentially i mean we look at this
formula right assets equal liability
plus equity if this is a million this is
750. what does what do i have left over
well i have 250 000
left over that's my equity
and i think hopefully
the concept of equity is making is
starting to make a little more sense
now we have
you know i could say that i have a
million dollars and some people are like
that they think they're a millionaire
when they have a million dollar of
assets but they don't consider well they
might have a million dollar assets but
they might owe other people nine hundred
thousand dollars so i wouldn't consider
that person a millionaire they're more
of a hundred thousand there
but your assets might be a million
dollars but you're not nearly a
millionaire because you still owe other
people 750 000 what you have left over
that really is your net worth or you
know what you can have claim to and
that's your equity sometimes it's called
owner's equity or if there was a bunch
of people pitching together it'd be
called shareholders equity and maybe
i'll do a little bit more on that in the
future
but hopefully now you can see that the
balance sheet starting to make a
starting to seem a little bit useful but
i have the cash and i took the loan i
took the loan from the bank
but now i still haven't bought the house
yet so what am i going to do well i'm
going to give my cash to the house to
the owner the old owner of the house or
maybe this toll brothers they just built
this mcmansion for me so i give them
one million dollars and in return they
give me the deed to the house or they i
could just say they give me the house
right it's the house is always there but
you know it's really just the contract
and all the legal structure that i get
around it and all the property rights
and all of that but that gets getting
into philosophical so now what does my
balance sheet look like instead of cash
and i think i'm running out of space and
time to draw another balance sheet i
don't have cash worth of million dollars
i now have a house worth a million
dollars assuming that it really is worth
it and that was the correct price i
didn't overpay whatever i now have my
assets are a million dollar house
and i owe the bank seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars so what's left over for
me is 250 000
of equity
i'm about to run out of time so i'm
going to leave you
from this video in the next video i'm
going to start explaining what happens
if the value of the house goes up or
down or you need cash and all of these
interesting things and
we'll start to learn a little bit more
about what's going on in the world see
you soon